Here in Chanel's Pantin Laboratory,...
...for ten years, we have been studying...
...the mechanism of skin aging called senescence,...
...basing our research on data from 6,000 women around the world...
...and working on 2D and 3D skin models...
...to test the efficacy of our active ingredients.
Senescence is the process by which a cell stops dividing...
...and enters a state of permanent growth arrest.
When these cells are treated with red Camellia extract,...
...their cellular vitality has increased by 67 percent.
Over here, we can see how senescence translates on a tissular level.
When skin is treated with red Camellia extract,...
...its oxidative state is rebalanced...
...for revitalized skin from the inside.
Beauty ahead of time.